but I think they have changed you read
the United Nations Development Report in
2001 before I started this project and
you really now some of the papers of
these projects have already been
published or mother was also a big
forest they have changed dramatically
the way they've see the world in 2001
they used to say that inequalities are
exploding all over the world now they
say that's not true they agree with me
that it's not true in 2001 they used to
say that poverty is increasing because
of the openness and globalization to lay
the agree that poverty is the planning
and its decline very rapidly that was
before the crisis how the financial
crisis of course will hurt a lot of poor
people and poverty in 2008 will go up
again but the trend since 1995 is with
very very very clear poverty is required
and they now agree that this is true so
I know I don't know if it's David and
Goliath that I think they might they
might be changing the way they see the
world in fact well in you know FC
Barcelona is like a like a nation we
have 170 thousand members each member
has a vote and the votes elect the
President and they are elections with
parties and we actually larger than many
countries were about the size of Iceland
and there was a no traditionally the
Board of Directors in the president of
FC Barcelona are traditionally they have
been all people all in the meaning 60s
with our people who devote the later
years of their lives to soccer and in
2003 a new generation of kids in their
30s decided to run for president who run
for board and we won and i was assigned
the presidency of the management
committee which essentially means
overseeing or the business side of
soccer at the sports io soccer but it
has an additional job which is when
there are when there is an electoral
process the president of the management
committee becomes the president of the
club follow election in 2006 I was the
president of the club during the
electoral process there was the fun